YouTube, okay.
Is it YouTube or my internet?
I wonder.
Is it YouTube or my internet, I wonder?
Oh!
It's coming back?
Perhaps.
It might be me.
I'm in a hotel.
I'm still in a hotel.
Let's roll the gift number.
Thank you.
No!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I just woke up.
I sound like an old lady.
Let me drink something.
I'm trying to open.
That's the stuff.
Wait, I think my noise gate is too...
Let me fix that real quick.
Sorry, I'm still...
Everything.
Wait a second, wait a second.
Maybe like this.
And also, tell me how...
The sound...
If I'm like too low.
Or anything.
Oh my gosh!
Hi guys!
Seems better, seems better, seems better.
Oh, it's good, it's good.
Wait, let me turn, take this.
It had a little, um, thingy on my mic.
Sounds muffled.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Hello guys!
You say welcome back, but I...
I'm still in Japan actually.
We're next...
So, sorry.
Next couple of days.
Sound quieter than usual.
I can turn that up.
One second.
Oh, oh, I made too much.
It's so sensitive.
I didn't even turn it up that much Hmm Oh my gosh this thing
is so sensitive I'm barely tapping it I'm barely tapping it
And it's like I
I Okay, I give
up.
I give up, maybe.
Maybe I give up.
I'm still a little bit sick.
My cough is...
Is very...
Much better.
But...
If I exert myself...
it like goes craziness and then I'm like oh no I'm gonna I'm
gonna puke um but yeah coughs are always the most stubborn
aren't they yeah it feels like I I can't I've said this a
million times to everybody else but it feels like I like I
got asthma or something from the sickie this time it's so
weird and yesterday I was doing some hiking and I was I had
to run at one point and I was like not okay but uh we're
okay we're Okay, everything's cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But the pollen, the pollen is getting to me.
Anybody else have allergies?
I guess it's that time of the year now.
What was chasing me?
The wild boars of Japan.
The boars of Japan.
I've been chasing me.
Did you guys know that there's like, apparently, feral...
Hold on, one second.
Feral boars in Japan are like a problem.
And bears.
Your allergies have been getting to you pretty bad.
Yeah.
30 to 50 wild hogs.
Why so many?
I saw I saw footprints of boars and I saw poop of deer crazy
the wildlife oh it's a reference to a tweet oh it's just so
many so many wild wild hogs
yeah i was in the nature of it all crazy you can tell which
animal the poop is from okay but i was told they were like
this is deer poop and then i became the poop detective and i
would have to find the poop so that we wouldn't step in it.
I held my title with very, with high regards, much dignity.
I said, ah, yes, I will take this mantle, the poop
detective.
And I will, I will honor, I will wear it, my badge with
honor.
Yes.
understandable well anyway guys today we're gonna sing a
little bit as you could tell probably i sound funny i sound
funny why did i choose karaoke i don't know because when you
are
feels right.
Oh my gosh, yes!
Yesterday I beat Portal 2!
I hope you guys who watched it, which everybody should,
maybe, if you feel like it.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
It was a lot of fun.
Me and Vicky, we've been talking about doing the Portal 2
co-op together, so that will probably be...
Sometime...
And I apologize that my streaming has been quite
non-existent.
Basically, the way I timed things was I get to Japan, I
acclimate a couple days, and that's when I have some portal.
then I can stream in the mornings and then I would get busy
the following week and that's when portal would resume and
that would be that but I got like so sick I got and and then
things started happening in the mornings and that's always
what happens on these trips is more so than just being busy
in general you know i try to stream in the mornings because
it's like uh that would be kind of a line with my normal
streaming time right uh jst so it's like 8 a.m for me i woke
up so early for you guys i'm just kidding I mean, I did, but
then things start happening.
Then it's just like, oh, no, we have to be on the train by 9
a.m.
Quite situation started happening.
And I'm like, okay.
At least I had portal.
Because I got so sick.
I got so sick.
I'm still recovering, as you can tell.
But I apologize.
I'm so sorry I'm so I was in bed for like Holy I was in bed
for A lot
But yeah I did have a blue archive and fatal frame And I had
The I amy family Live So there are you There are bits and
pieces of me about you could check you could you could see
me on the blue archive channel you could see me on
ayamimama's channel um fatal frame was here that was tough
because where i'm haunting and vicky's uh vicky's arcade was
so so far and so Yeah, I'm also a voice actor now.
Did you guys know that?
I am a featured cameo in the needy streamer girl anime.
Yeah, that was crazy.
But I kind of want to talk about it some, but I'm not sure
what all I can say.
I can say it was a terrifying experience.
because I had so many eyes on me and I had never done voice
acting before and so I they were like okay do the thing and
I'm like am I doing the thing correctly it was so scary my
lines were in Japanese I don't know if there's a English dub
for the show but whatever is out currently in theaters in
Japan is what I'm in so yeah yeah yeah but I think the show
itself airs in april so i um i uh and there
it's so crazy and then nyadudah a creator of needy girl he
was like it's really funny because i told him i was like i'm
too sick to go to the premiere i'm so sorry and he was like
he was like it's very funny because in the credits all the
names are japanese and then suddenly you see mint phantom in
english so maybe i stand out a little bit which is kind of
funny hold on i'm gonna drink some more juice give me the
juice give me the juice thank you so much for Thank you,
thank you.
Wait, wait, hold on.
Akko.
Thank you!
Now my voice acting arc has begun.
What else has happened?
I feel like for so much of this, I was...
In bed.
And nothing interesting was happening.
Sorry, my cough mostly happens when I laugh.
I can't...
I'm...
Oh, I can't enjoy afterlife anymore.
Because I just end up...
I can't be happy.
I
can't be happy.
Oh, got the collab cafe!
Yes, I had...
That is happening right now.
The Ayami Mama...
Ayami Family Collab Cafe 3.
That is happening.
Um...
I can't believe the dust from Vicky's room.
Maybe you coughed so bad.
Yeah.
No.
I was definitely sick before then.
Sick in the head.
I'm sick in the head.
But golly.
She came over after it.
She was like, I didn't have time to dust it.
i don't know girl when were you gonna dust that
i have a picture but i don't want to post it i took it as
like evidence as like uh as you know like you know if if
vicky tries to slander me no i i have the proof black not
blackmail
it's if she's just like it's not that bad oh yeah and then I
can be like you're so sure about that like pocket sand but
blackmail it's not blackmail it's an ace attorney tactic I
learned it from the best I learned it from Phoenix Wright
when he says Take that!
Why am I blinking?
I don't know.
I give up.
I'm sorry if I'm coughing a lot, you guys.
I also don't know how to mute easily on this, so...
My coughs will be...
dramatic.
And, uh...
Yeah.
Sometimes they sound totally good and sometimes they sound
totally bad.
What?
it doesn't hurt my throat doesn't hurt it doesn't it's all
good um shall we sing shall we sing i don't even know what
to sing what to sing someone tell me something
sorry down with the sickness actually don't Wait, I know
that song, but...
Some battle song.
You trying to kill me?
Again?
I'm sorry for coughing.
She said to her loyal freak servant...
Ew, don't say that.
Tequila.
I'm gonna drink some more.
I promise you, singing will not be a problem.
If I cough, it's because I just cough.
The cough comes...
No matter what.
You know what I mean?
The cough comes no matter what.
The cough is part of the song.
Special cough, sicky edition.
The cough is inevitable.
Alright, let's see.
How do I do this?
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow.
Yeah, let's sing a portal.
If you guys like the BGM, please go to the Densetsu EXE
channel because we have chill beats to study and save Akiba,
too.
And this is a bossa nova version of Densetsu MVPs.
So, you should listen to it on the Densetsu channel, please.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, God.
wait I'm being that guy that uh what was it the chocolate
rain guy I move away from the mic to cough I move away from
the mic to cough but I hope that you guys understand now why
I have not been streaming because I would sound like this a
lot of the time actually oh yeah someone just mentioned the
the the the oh manchudu hold on let me get that from my kid.
It wasn't even that bad this... That wasn't even that bad
the other night or yet last night.
I guess it was kind of bad yesterday but so bad this
morning.
It's sometimes it's fine in the mornings and sometimes it's
bad in the mornings.
It's all dependent.
Have a human churu.
Hingen no churu.
Oh you know.
Is that a good thing?
Are you more excited?
Isn't that just gogurt?
Oh yeah, maybe, right?
Come on.
Come on, come on.
You guys came for singing.
We're gonna sing.
Portal.
I don't know the second ending though yet.
I only know I'm still alive.
I don't know the second one.
I only heard it for the first time.
Yesterday.
Just kidding.
Now
let's play the music and see if it's odd too.
Let me make sure it's okay first.
I'm
mute real quick.
Let me make sure this is a karaoke version.
Yes.
Yes, it is.
All right.
Let me know.
I play.
they
well i'm gonna skip into the middle to see if it's too loud
all
the captain memberships you guys thank you all right all
right let's sing let me put this in the cellos no no still
alive because i just finished portal 2 even though this is
portal 1 all right let's go sorry i have no reverb i
realized right before stream i don't have it i'm so sorry
this was a triumph i'm making a note here huge success it's
hard to overstate my satisfaction aperture science We must,
because we can.
For the good of all of us, except the ones who are dead.
But there's no sense crying over every mistake.
You just keep on trying till you run out of cake.
I never got my cake!
Oh, people who are still alive.
Not even angry.
I'm being so sincere right now Even though you broke my
heart and killed me And tore me the pieces And threw every
piece into a fire Yeah, I did that As they burned it hurt
because I was so happy for you Now these points of data make
a beautiful line And we're out of beta, we're releasing on
time But I'm quite glad I covered Think of all the things we
learned For the people who are still alive
I think I prefer to stay inside Maybe you'll find someone
else to help you Maybe black mesa That was a joke, ha ha,
got chance.
Anyway, this cake is great.
It's so delicious and moist.
Look at me, it's still talking when there's science to do.
Look out there, it makes me glad I'm not you.
I've experiments to run.
There is research to be done on the people who are still
alive.
And believe me, I am.
I'm still alive I'm doing science and I'm still alive I feel
fantastic and I'm still alive While you're dying I'll be
still alive And when you're dead I will be still alive Still
alive Still alive
Oh no Oh, I don't have, I don't have a YouTube premium.
So you're going to get Japanese ads.
Are they going to play on everything?
I sure hope not.
Which ad?
This is one for some sort of doctor place.
Yes, I'm sorry.
all right yay that was uh that was um still alive real
important yay
I hope they don't pop up in the middle of a song here if you
want to I could well no I'm not going to finish this one I
don't know if it'll be like okay come to this doctor's
office right next to Minfantom's hotel.
You know?
That's A-O-K.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
I want to announce in like 20 minutes.
Is that okay with you guys?
Doxed by YouTube.
Luckily, I'm going home soon.
YouTube knows you're sick and it's trying to get you some
help.
Who was that guy?
Oh my gosh, there's a guy in Mint's room.
It's the doctor.
He's coming to take me away.
Oh my gosh, wait, what's that song?
They're coming to take me away, they're coming to take me
away, ho ho, hee hee, ha ha, to the funny farm where life is
beautiful all the time.
Yeah, Ado is in my room.
Realer than you think.
I don't even know if a doctor could help me at this point.
My brain is broke.
You're up soon.
Can you stop getting sick?
Thank you very much.
Let me just do that.
Yeah, I'm trying.
Oh, my gosh.
Isn't it so inconvenient for you guys when I get sick?
Isn't it so, isn't it just so, so much of a pain in the butt
for you guys when I am coughing up a long.
Man.
Yeah.
I get it.
Well, then I'm going to hack up a long real quick.
I'll mute.
Okay.
I'm going to sing.
Wait, hopefully...
Hold on.
Hopefully I'm going to turn off if there's an ad.
Oh, that'll play it.
Wait, I might get copyright struck, though.
Actually, this whole stream will probably get copyright
struck.
Oh, it's for Indeed.
Oh, my God.
Now they're telling me to get a job.
No way.
Employ yourself, streamer.
Get a real job.
No, no.
No.
YouTube has become my mom.
YouTube strike for, or copyright strike for an ad, yeah,
because they were playing music.
They were playing music, okay.
All right, all right.
Let me sing.
This is, I'm just singing whatever comes to mind.
So today, you can request, I will pick whatever I feel like
singing.
Because I feel like singing it.
I gotta take it for the long way round Two bottle of whiskey
for the way And I sure would like some sweet company And I'm
leaving tomorrow, what do you say?
When I'm gone, when I'm gone You're gonna miss me when I'm
gone You're gonna miss me by my hair, you're gonna miss me
everywhere You're gonna miss me when I'm gone When I'm gone
When I'm gone You're gonna miss me when I'm gone You're
gonna miss me by my walk You're gonna miss me by my taco
You're gonna miss me when I'm gone Actually it's funny, I
had a dream about Sabrina Carpenter last night
I got my ticket for the long way round The one with the
prettiest of views It's got mountains, it's got rivers It's
got sights to give you shivers But it sure would be prettier
with you When I'm gone When I'm gone You're gonna miss me
when I'm gone You're gonna miss me by my walk You're gonna
miss me by my taco You're gonna miss me when I'm gone When
I'm gone When I'm gone miss me when i'm gone you're gonna
miss me by my hair you're gonna miss me everywhere oh you're
gonna miss me when i'm gone when i'm gone when i'm gone
you're gonna miss me when i'm gone you're gonna miss me by
my walk you're gonna miss me by my taco you're gonna miss me
when i'm gone yeah okay now that i have a second i can
explain my dream okay so i was the opening act for uh some
idol show and i was singing a sabrina carpenter song but i
was trying mid song like mid performance to change the
lyrics to like uh i don't know to be related to me and so i
was like I was like in the song and I don't even remember
what I was doing, what I was saying, but I was like, I was
like trying to, trying to change it.
I don't think anybody was at the show, which is good because
it wasn't, I, I was, I was flopping.
Let's see.
We'll do Sabrina Carpenter.
Sabrina Carpenter.
Karaoke.
I did in fact miss me.
Oh.
Oh, I thought someone was knocking on my door.
I thought they were going to be like...
Housekeeping.
I'd be like, no.
I said do not disturb.
Oh.
Wait, do I remember how this one goes?
Let me see.
no no no oh sorry it's another ad this one is so annoying oh
my gosh it's for some trading card game or not trading card
game but some for some trading card site and it's these two
guys exchanging their business cards but they're trading
like the not pokemon cards and then here i'll just play it
because like they're like they're businessmen they're like
oh yes nice to meet you nice to meet you and then he hands
over the card and they turn into like little children and
Like, Suke!
Where did you get that card from?
Here, it happens like right now.
Here we go.
Okay, skip, skip, skip.
Now I can skip the ad.
Oh, I just clicked out of the...
Okay, look.
I watched a lot of YouTube when I was sick.
I know I have good judgment I know I have good taste It's
funny and it's ironic That I only, that only I feel that way
I promise them that you're different And everyone makes
mistakes But just Don't I heard that you're an actor So act
like a stand-up guy Whatever doubles inside you Don't let
him out tonight I'll tell him it's just your culture and
everyone rolls their eyes yeah i know all i'm asking baby
please please please don't prove i'm right and please please
don't bring me to tears when i just did my makeup so nice
heartbreak is one thing my ego is another i beg you You
don't embarrass me, mother fucker.
Oh.
Please, please, please.
I had an idea, babe, maybe just stay inside.
I know you're craving some fresh air, but the ceiling fan is
so nice, and we could live so happily if no one knows that
you're with me.
I'm just kidding, but really, really, really.
Please, please, please Don't prove I'm right Please, please,
please Don't bring me to tears When I just did my makeup so
nice Heartbreak is one thing My ego is another I beg you
don't embarrass me Motherfucker out please please I don't
really know this song so well thank you for the read that
break if you want to go and be stupid don't do it in front
of me what are these words if you don't want to cry to my
music don't make me hate you so prolifically please please
please please I'm just begging at this point boy.
I'm just, please, please.
There's this video.
There's this video that is, oh, sorry, I forgot to change
this.
That was, uh, that was, please, please, please fight Labrida
Carpenter.
There's this one video of this guy that's like, send this to
a baddie who's sad.
don't be sad baddie don't be sad please please please please
please please baddie don't be sad oh my gosh thank you so
much for the 50 gifts thank you guys for all the gifted
memberships today thank you thank you thank you so much um
give me one second i'm gonna get that announcement
Let's sing another song.
I'm going to sing a Disney song.
Sorry, this is the absolute most scuffed karaoke maybe ever
in the world.
Ah.
We'll do this one.
I could do both.
Both.
Oh, no, it's another ad.
Wait.
Okay, this one was quiet.
Okay, thank goodness.
Uber Eats not flow.
Oh no, no, no, no!
Where's the second ad?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, alright, I'll sing this.
The secret second ad.
Oh my gosh.
When does it start?
Can show you the world.
Shining shimmer.
Oh wait, this is Aladdin, isn't it?
Splendid.
Tell me, princess.
Now when did you last let your heart decide?
your eyes take you under by wonder over sideways and under
on a magic carpet ride a whole new one a new fantastic point
of view no one to tell us no on where Where to go?
Why is Aladdin evil?
A whole new world A dazzling place I never knew But when I'm
way up here It's crystal clear But now I'm in a whole new I
should get to I'm in a whole new world Unbelievable sides
describable feeling soaring tumbling freewheeling through an
endless diamond sky a whole new world a hundred thousand
things to see i'm like a shooting star i've come so far i
can't go back to where i used to be every turn a surprise
new horizons to to pursue.
I'll chase them anywhere if it's time to spare.
Let me share this whole new world with you.
A whole new world, a whole new world.
That's where we'll be, that's where we'll be.
A thrilling chase, a wondrous place for you.
and me
I told you I could do I could do both parts It's a one-man
show, baby
It's a one-man show
Okay Announcement incoming but before we announce i'm gonna
get some special people in here i'm joining
hello hello hello let me make hello hello hello hello hi hi
wait good morning good morning Oh, I just realized I didn't
give you guys a Fugies.
Hold on.
Wait, how do I find the Fugies?
Oh.
I don't know.
Wait.
Oh, here.
Oh, yeah, there's like a group link.
Oh, there is.
Oh, do you have?
Yeah, it's here.
Legacy.
Unlike me.
Here.
I think.
Is this the group?
I put it in the text chat.
Oh, thank you.
Wait.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I see.
Oh, is that cool?
Did it wore it?
Am I?
Oh, I'm going to try.
Let's try.
Da, da, da, da.
I think everybody already knows who your eyes are, though.
Oh, we're live.
Just realized.
Hello, chat.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yippee.
Hello.
Sorry.
Hello, guys.
Who are these weirdos?
Excuse me.
said that excuse me like my phone xbox mic then sensor dot
exe
what could the announcement be you guys what could it be
now we're all switching to xbox mics wait is my phone mic
really that bad is it better if i like it it has character
it does have character it's okay instead of speaker is it
better if i'm talking like this is it the same uh i think we
could all use a little more xbox mic wait can you tell me
that i have uno oh you have wait that you have uno you have
uno i don't it didn't come with my xbox it came with your
xbox
Yeah, that's our announcement is we're all switching to
Xbox.
Yeah.
Do we want to make the announcement then?
Oh, my God.
Are we ready?
Are we?
How are we doing this?
I don't know, actually.
There's a picture.
There's a picture that you can use and put on the screen.
Yeah, that's what I was about to do.
I have it.
I have it ready.
Are we ready?
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I'm gonna switch.
I'm gonna do it.
Announcement.
Three, two, one.
Nobody's making any noise.
Legend's anew!
Tencentu.exe first.
3D live!
Oh my gosh, we've been working so, so long.
hard on this everybody yeah we've been practicing hard so i
hope you guys will will be able to make it yeah please oh
look how convenient it's during off kai expo and it's near
off kai expo oh what what oh actually it is during off kai
expo but it is not a part of the con so you do not need a
badge to attend you can just you can just walk up with a
badge to or with a ticket to the show you don't say walk up
without a ticket you guys do need a ticket so how do we get
tickets well ticket info is on the website the website
legends and new dot com yeah wow that's so cool guys We have
our own domain for it.
Whoa!
And also, hey, I'm not going to Afkai Expo.
What do I do?
There will be streaming tickets!
Streaming tickets!
All the worldwide dead sheet could watch from wherever you
are.
Wherever you are.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Accessibility.
Oh!
Yeah!
so you can pre-register for the pre-sale starting literally
right now um if you are akiba defender on our patreon the
den zetsu patreon you can access it and you can sign in with
your patreon on the website and it will register you for
pre-sale so yes
pre-sale is gonna close on monday march 26 or sorry 23rd at
6 p.m.
Pacific.
And then the pre-sale itself begins the next day.
Yeah.
So you have to register for the pre-sale to do the pre-sale.
And then there will be general sales after.
Yeah.
General sales, they start Wednesday, March 25th at 10 a.m.
Pacific.
Yeah.
Oh, I saw someone in chat say that there are slots for
special guests.
Oh!
I'm not gonna Vicky leaks that one so you guys are just
gonna have to wait for some announcements soon.
It's... yeah.
Very cool.
I just hid this.
Who could they be?
I don't think anybody will know actually.
i really don't think so you guys you guys can guess but i
don't think you know at all
actually what we're doing for this concert is something
extremely extremely unique so so that's why that's why you
may not be able to guess like like maybe maybe one of them
maybe but like
You'll just have to find out, huh?
I know.
But yeah.
Can you believe it, guys?
It still doesn't feel real that this is happening.
I know!
My gosh.
We've been working super duper hard, you guys.
So...
Why are you like without seeing yourself?
No, I mean, I guess...
I moved myself.
Oh, there you go.
Cute, cute, minto.
I'm a Taka, I'm a, I'm a, a Shingeki no Kyojin right now.
I'm a, I'm a humanity reversing the Krim reminder.
No, don't eat me.
Ashley, you can eat me.
It's fine.
But, you know, I feel like this is July.
I wonder if we'll, you know, we have Densetsu MVPs.
Hmm.
A while from now, you guys.
A while from now.
Yeah.
And we've been, we've been collecting voices for a, for a
something, something.
Oh, we might.
Oh, yeah.
Which, by the way, you guys have like 12 days to, to get, to
get that in.
Yes.
Oh, we need your voices.
We're like Ursula and the little mermaid.
Yes, keep singing.
Poor unfortunate Denchi.
Give us your voices.
Yes.
Yeah, I see some of you guys saying you need to do that.
You should.
So who knows, maybe there are a few other surprises we're
cooking for this concert.
you'll have to see you'll have to see july 24th 8 p.m yeah i
can't even explain to you guys how excited we are to be able
to make this a reality so it would mean so much to us if
you're able to you know come and see us in person and for
those who can't you know get a streaming ticket oh yeah
we're just we're just so excited so heck yeah so and those
of you that are saying no california again there are
streaming tickets streaming tickets yeah you know i i
understand that a lot of stuff happens in california
unfortunately it's just a hub for people it can't be helped
but it's also during off kai weekend so um i think i think i
feel like if you notice that a lot of events happen where
they do it's usually typically um how do you say like during
events and cons and stuff yeah
i'm so excited i'm i'm nervous i've been so nervous i'm
nervous i'm getting a little butterfly
good good butterflies though to all be all be you know
standing on this the same stage as you guys and and you know
a huge step of all of our dreams and hopes you know so yeah
nervous but so excited i got containing yeah oh gosh and 3d
live which means all three of us be in 3d oh what does that
mean wow could it be a uh certain someone's a debut oh yeah
could be a certain yeah maybe 3d could be you'll have to
wait and find out you'll have to wait and find out
I'm so excited Oh my god I'm so So excited I think my I love
you guys I love you guys I'm still I'm still recovering from
Yaki Niku last night Yes Recovering from Wapah What for
dinner
I ate so much Me too Yeah It was so good though I think my
YouTube is crashing Oh geez Oh no Oh Hopefully it's okay
YouTube come back Announcement too powerful Yeah Yippee
Yippee Thank you so much everybody For getting hyped for our
announcement And for meant for having this pop in for a bit
on your stream you've been sounding lovely yeah oh thank you
hear what you sing next do you guys have anything i should
sing i have no idea i'm too tired to think uh
that's okay you don't have chippy chapa chapa chapa chapa
chapa chapa
Uh, Phoebe, you got any ideas?
We should sing Pumpkin Hill.
Pumpkin Hill!
Okay, I'll sing Pumpkin Hill.
Yay!
Thank you, girls!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much, Mindo!
Of course!
Have a good rest of your stream and get hyped, then she!
Yeah!
Wow!
My boy!
Yay!
Oh my gosh, Steiner, so hold on, he was yelling at us.
Tell them the tickets won't be via Ticketmaster.
The people need to be reassured there's no Ticketmaster.
Ticketmaster!
Okay.
Okay, I'll respond.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Honestly, when we say that there's stuff that you will not
expect for this concert, we do quite mean it.
It's kind of, um, uh, yes.
We've been doing a lot of things that maybe you would not
expect.
So it's kind of fun.
And we're really, really excited for it.
And if you, we're not going to be in the area.
We're really excited that we can also do streaming tickets.
So, yeah.
So we're very, very excited.
Our first 3D live, the three of us together.
So, um...
Yeah!
Yes, yes, yes.
Extra hush-hush secret stuff.
Secret.
Secrets.
We have secrets.
You don't even know.
You don't even know our secrets.
First of many.
I hope so.
And luckily it's during Off-Kai weekend, so if you were
already going to be at Off-Kai, it will be very easy to go
to, hopefully.
You could tell me.
Okay, I'll whisper it to you.
This is for your ears only.
And then another bow.
That is a long secret.
Yeah.
I know.
Crazy, right?
Oh, I feel like I should have had the music on.
My bad.
I should have put on.
I should have put on the song.
But one thing.
too is you know we have a den set to MVPs right we have a
den set to MVPs maybe or you know you might hear it live we
might be performing it live maybe oh we've been practicing
so much together though So, yes, we'll do our best.
We will do our best.
We'll do our best.
Yeah, yeah!
Oh, geez.
The next guest is...
Sorry that YouTube seems to be...
I'm waiting.
Okay.
Buffering?
You too, please.
Actually, I think it's my end.
Maybe I...
thought the hotel Wi-Fi would be enough, but it is not.
Usually hotel Wi-Fi in Japan is pretty good, actually, so...
It's not recovering.
Give me a second.
I will switch to...
What?
Can I switch to?
Can I switch to hotspot, I wonder?
Hmm.
That's not recovering.
I'll try a hotspot.
Lower the bit rate.
Oh, I can try that too.
Let's try.
Oh?
No.
It's for like three seconds.
Maybe it's okay, actually.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh.
Oh, I see it.
It just...
It gets better and then it gets worse.
Audio is not cutting off this time.
Oh, that's good, that's good, that's good.
Okay, hold on.
At least we were able to make the announcement.
I will switch the hotspot.
And I'll sing a couple more songs.
And then I'll take a nap.
Let's see.
Alright, give me it.
I'm gonna stop the stream for like two seconds.
It might be longer than...
Hold.
Hmm.
Might be worse.
Maybe it is YouTube then.
Maybe.
I just basically restarted the internet.
Ah, I think.
Better.
Perhaps.
Slayer back.
For now, I think so.
Yay!
The whole internet.
Yeah, so if you felt the little hiccup, it was me.
Literally in the mainframes.
In the servers.
Yeah!
Let's sing a song then.
Before everything goes to hell.
Before it all goes to hell.
Thank you guys for being so patient with me.
me thank you for the support out i hope you feel better and
have fun for the rest of your day thank you so much thank
you thank you thank you let's see
okay okay okay okay what do i want to sing now oh i was
gonna sing uh what was it pumpkin hill
i don't know the song very well wait
let me make sure this works I think it does oh there's an ad
good thing I muted the ad it's for Air France where are you
telling me to go they're like get out of Japan go to France
pants.
Okay, I'm gonna wrap now.
You know me, the fighting freak knuckles, and we're at
Pumpkin Hill.
You ready?
I ain't gonna let it get to me.
I'm just gonna creep down in Pumpkin Hill.
I got to find my last piece.
I know that it's here.
I can sense it in my feet.
The great emerald's power allows me to feel.
I can't see a thing, but it's around somewhere.
no fear this probably seems crazy crazy graveyard theory a
ghost tried to approach me and it got leery asked him a
question and he vanished in a second i'm walking through
valleys crying pumpkins in the alley didn't seem happy but
they sure tried to get me had to pack them up with the fist
metal crack them i'm hearing someone say you're a chicken
don't be scared they had to be the wind because nobody
wasn't there i searched in i searched as i climbed up the
wall and then i started to fly i went in deeper let it get
to me i'm just gonna creep Down in Pumpkin Hill, I got this
to find my lost piece I know that it's here, I sense it in
my feet The great emerald's power allows me to feel I can't
see a thing, but it's round somewhere I gotta hold my head,
I have no fear It's probably seems crazy, crazy, graveyard
theory A ghost tried to approach me, he got leery Mic drop
This is Knuckles, who fears none
it's a real deal when it comes to my name kid the best
lyrics of our time I ain't gonna let it get to me I'm just
gonna creep down in pumpkin hill I've got to find my last
piece I know that it's here I could sense it in my feet but
every emeralds power allows me to feel I can't see a thing
but it's around here somewhere I'm gonna hold my head
because I have no fear this probably seems crazy crazy
graveyard theory a ghost tried to approach me and it got
leery asked him a question and he vanished in a second i'm
walking through valleys crying pumpkins in the alley didn't
seem happy but they sure tried to get me had to back them up
with a fist metal crack them i hear someone saying you're a
chicken don't be scared it had to be the wind because nobody
wasn't there i searched and i searched as i climbed up the
wall and then i started to fly i went in deeper let it get
to me to find my lost piece I know that it's here I sense it
in my feet the great emeralds power allows me to feel I
can't see a thing but it's around somewhere I gotta hold my
head I have no fear it probably seems crazy crazy a
graveyard theory a ghost tried to approach me he got leery
spooky up in here it's crazy in here we still gotta keep it
going I'm knuckles Nobody scares me?
Oh, I was early.
Nobody scares me.
Whoever won it, bring it.
I don't care what we do.
Then come step up to the plate and meet your match.
It ain't no thing.
Oh, sorry, I forget about the ads.
I forget about the ads.
This one's for some baseball thing.
gonna give them free advertising though that was a pumpkin
hill I'm
adding it to there we go pumpkin hill a ghost pumpkin soup I
love pumpkin I love pumpkin it was fire thank you thank you
thank you very much
Mmm, pumpkin.
Mmm, absolute cinema.
Thank you.
Never tried that pumpkin herring soup from that Jibli movie.
I've never tried a Jibli movie recipe before.
Mmm, pumpkin.
Mmm, let's see.
What if I do more Disney?
What if we do before a whole new world?
But sometimes BB and I will just be walking around and I'll
start meowing a song and she meows with me meow meow meow
my voice is I still have a morning voice sorry guys I didn't
warm up at all I woke up and said okay time to stream
but I've warmed up enough that I'm not coughing so much See,
I told you it'll be okay.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow.
Okay, I'll sing this song.
Sorry, today's karaoke's are a little more just like goofy
silly than actual...
Well, I'm singing, sort of.
Cat-themed Disney song.
Yes, there's the Aristocats.
Let's get down to business To defeat the Huns Meow Did they
send me daughters When I asked for sons You're the saddest
bunch I've ever met But you can bet before we're through Mr.
Ryle Make a man out of you.
Tranquil as a forest, but on fire within.
Yeah, make a cat out of you.
Once you find your center, you are sure to win.
You're a spineless, pale, pathetic lot.
Got a coup.
Somehow I'll make a cat out of you.
I'm never gonna catch my meow.
Say goodbye to those who meow me.
Boy, was I a fool in school for cutting me out.
This guy's got him scared to meow.
Hope he doesn't meow right through me.
Now I really wish that I knew how to meow.
Great Thai food.
We're raging fire.
Mysteries on the dark side of the meow.
Time is racing towards us till the dogs arrive.
Heed my every order and you might survive.
for the rage of war.
So pack up, go meow, you're through.
How could I make a cat out of you?
We must be swift as the coursing river with all the force of
a great typhoon with all the strength of a raging fire
mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
We must be swift as the coursing river, with all the force
of a great typhoon, with all the strength of a raging fire,
mysterious as the dark side of the moon.
Be a cat.
I don't know why it was so good where it was just like I
really wish that I knew how to meow yeah this is what us a
lot sings to gruesome
Oh, it's too good.
Too good.
Let's see.
OcelotMiao with Reverb.wev.
I'm like, I put in like karaoke and I'm just kind of like
going through and seeing what.
What comes up?
Oh my gosh, that's me.
singing Santa baby oh that's embarrassing why did that come
up
now we can do the sad meow meow song what is that hold on
the Billy Island what was I made for right what was I made
for karaoke meow meow meow meow meow they
don't know this how it goes loud
wait it's the full now I just fall down I used to know but
I'm not sure now what was I made for what was I made for
taking the I wasn't ideal Looks so alive Turns out I'm not
real Something you paid for What was I made for?
Cause I Desire I don't know how I don't know how to feel But
I want to try I don't know how to feel Cause someday I don't
know, it's part of my Someday I might
Meow, meow, meow, meow Meow, meow
Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew,
Mew, Mew, Mew,
Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew,
Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew, Mew,
Mew, Mew.
Such powerful lyrics.
Just finished re-watching your entire Ghost Trick
playthrough.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Oh, oh.
What was I meowed for?
Legends of Mew.
We're mewing.
We're Mewing.
We're a meow maxing.
I'm being stressed What was I meowed for?
Because I'm y'all Okay, serious, not serious But we sing a
song I'll sing it proper I sing it proper But what's wrong?
Do I say?
seven
proper meow take on me kind of fun have i sung this song
before do i
yeah i remember how it goes okay i think yeah i'll try to
hold back the meow oh oh that's an ad sorry for nutella
biscuits why are ads in japan ads japan they get nutella and
levi jeans oh wait this is the intro
take on meow oh no don't say that i'll Let's do it.
We're talking away, meowing away.
I don't know what to say, I'll say it anyway.
Today's another day to find you, shying away.
I'll be coming for your love, okay?
Meow.
Needless to meow.
On odds and ends, I'll out of fear, stumbling away.
Learning that life is okay Say after me It's no better to be
safe and sorry Meow All
the things that you say Is it a life or just to blame?
I was away You're all the things I've got to remember You're
shying away I'll be coming for you anyway Take care I
thought it was a day or two Day
In a day or two Baby I don't know anymore It doesn't
In a meow or two
Ah We could do this one Wait, hold on Now it's giving me
like Ew, ew, ew, what the hell was this ad Sorry, it was
like they were like slurping on something oh it's a gym
protein ad um oh what was i gonna say they're giving me 80
songs oh wait i think it's playing the intro do i remember
this one we'll try
this is me because i'm day in
let's meow in style let's meow for a while heaven can't wait
we're only watching the Hoping for the best but expecting
the worst Are you gonna drop the meow or not?
Let us die young or let us live forever We don't have the
power but we never say never Sitting in a meow pit Life is a
short trip The music's for the sad man Can you imagine when
this race is won?
Turn our golden faces into the sun Getting into the music's
played by the map Forever,
time, forever Want
to meow forever Something,
somewhere like water Somewhere like the heat The beat,
sooner or later Why don't they stay young?
I don't know if I'm getting this right Cause I don't want to
meow Like a fading cat Feels like a diamond in the sun And
diamonds are forever!
So many adventures couldn't happen today So many songs we
forgot to play So many dreams swinging out of the blue We
let them come true Forever meow I want to be forever meow
Forever meow I want to be forever meow of a meal.
Sorry.
What about this one?
Oh, sorry.
This is an ad.
Oh my gosh.
I can't get over the ads.
Need to install an ad blocker.
Right after the stream.
I forgot.
Where's my YouTube premium?
It's not on this account.
I hear
the meows echo, but she hears only mews, whispers of them,
quiet conversation.
She's coming in 1230 flight.
Our moonlit wings reflect the stars that guide me towards
salvation.
I stopped an old man along the way, hoping to find some old
for forgotten meows are ancient melody He turned to me as if
to sing Hurry meow, it's waiting there for you It's gonna
take a lot to meow me where
it could ever do I bless the meows down in Africa
Maybe I should put on my cat ears The wild dogs cry out in
the night as they grow so restless longing for a solitary
company.
I know that I must do what's right, sure as Kilimanjaro
rises like Olympus above the Serengeti.
I seek to meow what's deep inside, brightened up this thing
that I've become.
It's gonna take a lot to meow me away from you There's
nothing that a hundred men or more could ever do I've
blessed the meows down in Africa Gonna take some time to do
Three boys, she's meowing there for you
Could ever do I've blessed the meows down in Africa
Everybody I bless the meows down in Africa I bless the meows
down in
Africa Oh wait I don't know this song but I kind of want to
do it with a meow No, no, no, no, no, no, stop, stop, stop
Everybody meow together Everybody meow together Now I'm just
getting like request or not request but like the YouTube is
like you should sing this song next
Right now he's probably slow dancing with a bleach blonde
tramp and she's probably getting frisky Right meow he's
probably buying her some fruity little drink cause she can't
shoot Meow ski right now he's probably up behind her with a
pool stick showing her how to shoot a meow bow and he don't
know.
I dug my key into the side of his pretty little soup the
four-wheel drive, my name, into his leather seats.
I took a loose lugger to both headnights.
I slashed a hole in all four tires.
Maybe next time he'll think before he knows.
Right now she's probably up singing some white trash version
of Shania karaoke.
Right now she's probably saying meow and he's thinking that
he's gonna gotta get lucky.
Right now he's probably down on the ground.
You don't know.
And I dunked my key into the sun.
Pretty little souped up four-wheeled trash.
I brought my name into his leather seat.
I took a loose lugger to both his lines.
Let's smash the hole in all four tires.
Maybe next time he'll fit before he meows.
Oh, I saved the trouble for the next cat girl.
I don't know this part.
Cause the next time that he meows, No, you know it won't be
on me.
No, not on me.
Gown my key into the side of his pretty little suit, the
four-wheel drive, part my name to his leather seats.
I took the Louisville slugger to both headlights, Slashed a
hole in all four tires Maybe next time he'll fit before he
meows Oh maybe next time he'll fit before he before he Meows
I don't know how that song goes Or he meows
Cheating ass Tomcat Yeah Oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry i
think that was really loud too i'm so sorry
xbox that wasn't xbox that was an xbox
meowing my way downtown walking fast faces pass and i'm home
yawned
I'm staring blankly ahead, just making my way, making my way
through the meows.
Miam, miam, miam, miam, miam, miam, miam, and I'm yes, you.
And now I wonder if I could meow into the sky.
Do you think time would pass me by?
Cause you know I'm meow a thousand miles So if I could just
see you tonight
There's always times like these when I think of you And I
wonder if you ever meow of me Cause everything's so wrong
that I don't belong Meowing in your precious memory
Cause I still need you Oh, and I'll miss you Oh, I always
got the wrong part And now I'm yonder If I could yell into
the sky Do you think time would pass me by Cause you know
I'd walk a thousand meows if I could just see you tonight.
Face is passing, I'm homebound.
Staring blankly ahead, just meowing my way, meowing my way
through the crowd.
I still need you And I still meow mule And now I wonder If I
could meow Into the sky You think time Would pass us by
Cause you know I'd walk A thousand meows If I could just see
you If I could meow into the sky Do you think time would
pass me by?
Cause you know I'd walk a thousand meows If I could just
sing If I could just meow you Tonight
thousand meows.
It feels like I've said a thousand meows at this point.
It feels like it.
Okay.
I'm gonna do two more songs, guys.
Two more songs.
I hope that's okay.
I hope you're enjoying the meow-yokey.
My mom keeps asking me why I'm meowing in my
Meowing just brings joy.
You know?
Meowiyoki!
Country Roads!
Oh, I wasn't getting...
Okay, maybe three more songs.
Country Meow's!
Country Roads!
It's like a bunch of classic songs, too, so it's kind of
fun.
Wait.
We'll do the ad.
Okay, I turned it off.
I was fast.
I was the fastest fingers in the West.
I would meow a thousand meows and I would meow a thousand
more.
Wait.
Almost heaven.
West Virginia.
Blue Ridge Mountains.
Shenandoah.
Life is old there Older than the meows Younger than the
mountains Blowing like a breeze Country meows Take me meow
To the place I can't go so high Meow, meow, meow Go, I'll go
lower Take me, meow, country meows Oh, my meow,
minor's lady, stranger to blue, meow, meow, meow, dark and
dusty, painted on the sky Misty taste of meowshine, teardrop
in my eye, country meows Take me, meow, to the place I,
meow, whispered in meow, Meow did my mouth, take me, meow
Her voice in the morning hour she calls me The radio reminds
me of my home far away Driving down, oh, meowing down the
road I got the feeling that I should have been meowed
yesterday, yesterday.
Hunter meow, take me meow to the place.
I meow, West Virginia, meowing to mama, take me meow.
Meow Puntry Meow Take home To the place
West Virginia Meow Meow did my mouth
Puntry Meow Take me meow
Puntry Meow Puntry Meow Puntry Meow Okay, okay
Oh, I forgot the ad
I'm doing all these through YouTube Please understand And I
forgot to install ad blocker
What a meow With darkness and silence through the night What
a meow I'm meowing and I'll meowing to you What a meow in my
heart But you're so supreme
Meow Not for honor But for you Meow Eat up In my time
There'll be no other meow
It's the way I meow to you I'm still Meow, meow, weed
up.
Someday you go, meow.
Someday you feed, meow.
This ordeal, the meow to survive.
For the day we see new meow.
I give a meow, a full run.
But
when I die There'll be no other meow
It's the way I meow to you I'm still in a meow Meow eat
I'm still in a meow
My tummy's starting to rumble.
I didn't have breakfast yet.
So one last song.
One last song.
Oh, there's an ad.
Hold on, it's playing.
So I, oh my gosh, wait, oh, I was gonna say it's been so
short of a stream, but it has been a little bit short, but
it was, I might, since I had to restart OBS, it says that it
was less than an hour.
I was like, no, there's no way.
We're no strangers to meow.
You know the meows, and so do I.
Careful commitments, would I meow enough?
any other time.
I just want to meow you how I'm feeling.
Gotta make you understand.
Never gonna meow you up.
Never gonna meow you down.
Never gonna meow around and desert you.
Never gonna meow you cry.
Never gonna say meow.
Never gonna tell a lie.
And meow you.
We've known along.
Your meow's been aching but you're too shy to meow it.
I'm sorry we both know what's been going on.
We know the meow and we're gonna meow it and
you're too blind to see me.
Never gonna meow you up, never gonna meow you down, never
gonna meow around,
and it's never gonna Always gonna meow, never gonna meow.
Always gonna meow, always gonna meow.
We've known each other for so long.
Your meow's been aching, but you're too meow.
Try to meow it.
Inside we both know what's been going on.
We know the game and we're gonna meow it.
I just wanna meow you how I'm feeling.
Gotta make you understand.
Never gonna meow, you owe Never gonna run, meow around and
Just a word Never gonna say, meow Never gonna tell a lie
Never gonna say, meow Never gonna tell
And I hope you enjoyed the very exciting announcement The
legends are new With the little, with the little kawamoji
Then to the DXE, first 3D live We'll all be in 3D We'll all
be dancing, we'll all be singing Wow, we...
No, I go, thank you!
Meow Yuki!
What'll you do meow?
Yeah, I'll take a cat nap.
That sounds great.
Cat nap sounds awesome.
Thank you guys!
Keep meowing.
I will stream tomorrow as well.
I'll stream tomorrow too.
um so uh i should be able to maybe an hour later i could
sleep a little bit more
yuppie oh thank you thank you thanks to the meowie okay
congrats on the big announcement can't wait to see the 3d
thank you thank you thank you and hopefully if this is a
rousing success i would love to go other places right so
we'll do our best we've been practicing very very much a lot
very hard so i'm a bit tired mr so meow charito thank you
thank you thank you thank you dan sets the world tour Let's
go!
Let's go!
Let's go, world tour!
Maybe.
One day.
Hopefully.
Oh gosh.
I'm a hungry ghost.
Anybody have any...
I almost said sacrifices.
Any...
offerings.
I will gladly take them.
MVP, world tour.
We'll do your wedding.
We'll do your birthday.
day you just finished dinner taters i think i'm gonna go
mass burger maybe clover sounds awesome actually i had yaki
niku last night i probably shouldn't have any more meat
I volunteer as tribute Offering my sobriety dog Oh, that's
my alarm to wake up usually
Back at my maid cafe Back like at home home Ramen sounds
good Soba I love soba Cats are carnivores So more and more
meat so true okay i'm gonna go well i'm regardless i'm gonna
go eat oh so miento oh so miao miao thank you everybody
thank you so much thank you thank you i will see you when i
see you next oh so mito i so mito i so mito eat it a show
you have a good day have a good night have a good time zone
and i'll see you later oh so miao miao miao miao thank you
for all the super chats and all the gifted today thank you
so much thank you thank you thank you and the donuts too
though those ones are a little harder for me to see at the
moment because of uh my setup oh it's a meow meow oh it's a
meow bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye thank you thank you
bye bye like copy again bye bye